hi I'm Nick Gillespie of Reason I'm with
Matt Welch also of reason this is ask a
libertarian 2012 we've got our paperback
edition of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America it's
coming out at the end of the month
please buy it at your local bookstore
preorder it on Barnes and noble.com or
amazon.com it comes with a great new
forward where we update last year's
publication with sections about Occupy
Wall Street and all of the developments
that have happened in the meantime all
of which by the way support our basic
thesis that politics is the lagging
indicator of American society and people
are getting more libertarian and we're
eventually going to drag politicians
kicking and screaming into a better
future but now we're asking we're
answering all questions that you send
for the next five hours Matt what's our
first question Walt more sense by email
I'm frequently asked to come up with a
libertarian government throughout
history and can't come up with one can
you I would say you're right we haven't
had a purely libertarian government
throughout history but in a way that's
kind of the wrong way of looking at it I
think that we use libertarianism in the
book as not necessarily the Utopia in
which we will once roll around in the
future but rather as an impulse towards
getting towards a more free and
prosperous place it's a pre political
impulse rather than a specific Valhalla
out there and then more generally I
think since 1800 or so beginning in
America and elsewhere we have seen
abroad kind of sense of liberal
democracy and capitalism that has
broadly worked you wouldn't describe it
purely as libertarian for sure but
compared to everything else in human
history it has been so much more
libertarian than anything that preceded
on it and now we need to actually get
better at that yeah you know another
great demonstration project and that's
what we talk a lot about in the book or
demonstration products of lived liberty
or freedom and innovation and change and
decentralization that impulsive math
talk about is the Internet the Internet
is largely self-governing or where
people can choose different kinds of
frameworks it's it's hardening up a
little bit so we'll have to push in
to a new frontier but the Internet is
one example as is American history with
many many problems in it but that pushed
towards decentralization towards letting
individuals make more meaningful choices
of what's going on in their life and
this is one of the reasons why 2012 is a
hugely important year whether it's
conservatives or liberals Republicans or
Democrats you're seeing an attempt to
really centralize all many aspects of
our lives which goes against all the
good things that are happening in our
lives we'll be here all day ask a
libertarian stay tuned